Os garantizo que una de las cosas que más te sorprenden  cuando llegas a Japón
- y la verdad son muchas las cosas que te sorprenden -  son la seguridad y la confianza que se siente.
Veréis, Japón es uno de los poco países
del mundo donde te puedes dejar un IPhone X
en una cafetería, por ejemplo, y volver
al día siguiente tranquilamente a por él.
Porque, amigos, casi con total seguridad,
tu IPhone X, nuevecito, recién estrenado,
va a estar allí esperándote.
Y no, no estoy exagerando. Por supuesto, puedes
tener mala suerte pero no es lo habitual.
Además, amigos, Japón, es un país precioso
con rincones increíbles, donde todo parece
estar donde tiene que estar.
Por mi parte
os lo recomiendo como destino, Japón nunca
defrauda.
Pero…cómo sabéis este no es un canal de
viajes… ni un este un vídeo patrocinado
por el Ministerio de Turismo de Japón, así
que… al grano.
Recientemente, amigos, hemos conocido que
el emperador Akihito a decidido abdicar.
(“Japón anuncia que el emperador Akihito
abdicará en abril de 2019”. La Vanguardia.)
Pues bien, atentos al dato: este emperador llego al trono hace casi 30 años, en 1989...
justo el año en que comenzó la gran crisis japonesa.
No, cuidado, en Japón el emperador no tiene
ningún poder, así que Akihito no ha sido
responsable, pero no me digáis que no es
coincidencia y mala suerte.
Prácticamente podemos decir que fue llegar
Akihito y… 30 años de estancamiento.
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a ver qué pasó, qué
causó esta gran crisis y porque el modelo
alemán ha conseguido batir al modelo japonés.
Pero antes, amigos, veamos un poquito de historia.
LOS MILAGROS EXISTEN
Japón y Alemania son dos países muy interesantes,
con muchas coincidencias
y también, con muchas diferencias.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial los dos países
estaban, literalmente en ruinas. Habían perdido
no solo sus infraestructuras, sino prácticamente
también a toda una generación.
(Sin embargo, entre los años 50 y los años
70 los dos países vivieron un despegue tan
importante que en esas dos décadas no solo
consiguieron recuperarse, sino que lograron
convertirse en dos de las mayores economías
del mundo y en dos de los países más ricos.)
De hecho, aunque hoy suene increíble durante
años se llegó a especular con que Japón
podría llegar a superar a los mismísimos
Estados Unidos como la mayor economía del mundo.
¡Cómo han cambiado las cosas!
El caso es que entre 1955 y 1973, Japón creció
una media anual del 9%, y del 73 al 90,
por encima del 4%. Unos datos de matrícula.
Y Alemania, ojo, no se quedó atrás, tuvo crecimientos
medios del 7% anual durante casi 30 años.
Las dos locomotoras, amigos, estaban a pleno
rendimiento. Las fábricas de los dos países
trabajan a destajo, el paro no existía, y
tanto alemanes como japoneses ahorraban e
invierten su dinero por todo el mundo.
De repente, las empresas japonesas y alemanas
comenzaron a cobrar fama y a ser conocidas
mundialmente.
Algo que tiene mucho mérito, especialmente
en el caso de Japón, un país que por así
decirlo vive bajo el constante acoso de la
naturaleza…
(Además de ser un país muy montañoso, Japón
sufre todo tipo de desastres naturales: terremotos,
ciclones, maremotos, tsunamis, etcétera,
etcétera.)
De hecho, amigos, como anécdota, os contaré
que en la primera noche que pasé en Tokyo
experimenté un terremoto de grado 5,3; que
aunque no es muy grande sí te hace experimentar
lo que pueden suponer.
[Por cierto, en próximos vídeos, aquí en
VisualPolitik, os contaremos con detalle cómo
se produjeron estos dos “milagros económicos]
El caso es que en 1989 todo este despegue
económico se frenó, llegó a su fin y dio
paso a lo que ya se conoce como el gran estancamiento japonés.
(“Japón se hunde en la 'tormenta perfecta':
estancamiento, burbuja y deuda” LibreMercado.)
Lo se, estoy convencido de que todo esto no
es nuevo para vosotros. Al fin y al cabo,
no es extraño que cada vez que se hable de
Japón termine haciendo presencia, antes o
después la palabra crisis.
Sí, desde que tengo uso de memoria Japón
ha sido algo así como el país de la crisis
eterna, el país que tiene un año bueno y
tres malos.
De hecho, hoy podemos decir claramente que
Alemania ha sido por así decirlo la gran
vencedora en esa carrera por el crecimiento
que los dos países mantuvieron durante décadas.
(Hoy Alemania - que, ojo, también ha pasado
malos momentos en las últimas décadas - es
más rica, tiene unas cuentas públicas mucho
más saneadas, es más competitiva a nivel
internacional y encima los alemanes tienen
salarios más altos.)
Fijaos, para hacernos una idea de cual es
la situación de Japón, creo que nos basta
con dos datos muy, pero que muy reveladores.
Primero, en Japón los salarios reales, esto
es teniendo en cuenta la inflación, son hoy
inferiores, ojo, a los salarios que los japoneses
tenían en 1990, ¡hace 30 años!
Y segundo, la deuda pública del gobierno
japonés es la más alta del mundo: supone
el 250% del PIB, sí el 250%, lo habéis escuchado
bien.
Así que amigos, creo que aquí la pregunta
que muchos os estáis haciendo es ¿Qué diantres
ocurrió? ¿Qué ha hecho que el modelo alemán
sea mucho mejor que el modelo japonés?
Pues… evidentemente razones hay muchas,
pero creemos que 3 de ellas son, con diferencia,
las más importante. Veamoslas.
UN MODELO PROBLEMÁTICO
En primer lugar, podemos decir que hubo una
gran diferencia entre el desarrollo de Japón
y el de Alemania.
El país del sol naciente, amigos, apostó
por proteger a grandes conglomerados industriales,
los Keiretsu.
Los keiretsu son por así decirlo una especie
de holdings que hacen prácticamente de todo,
es decir, que tienen empresas que se dedican
a todo tipo de cosas:, coches, aviones, neumáticos,
pasta de dientes…
(Todo fabricado por un mismo holding, cuyas
empresas se apoyan entre sí, se compra y
venden productos entre ellas y que incluso
llegaron a tener sus propios bancos para financiarse.
El problema de todo esto es que estos grandes
conglomerados tendían a ser muy burocráticos
y poco flexibles. Por así decirlo, en ellos
tomar decisiones era un proceso difícil y muy lento.
Pero...para compensar todas estas desventajas,
ahí estaba el gobierno japonés que no dudo
en darles todo tipo de ventajas y privilegios.
Por ejemplo, los financiaba generosamente,
a tipos anormalmente bajos, a través
de programas específicos del Banco Central
de Japón.
Sin embargo, amigos, los resultados al final
no fueron nada, pero que nada buenos.
(Fijaos, estos grandes grupos se hicieron
muy influyentes en la política del país;
escondían muchos problemas, porque claro,
cuando a una empresa de estos conglomerados
le iba mal era muy fácil que contagiará
al resto;
estaban muy endeudadas; y por si fuese poco
limitaban la competencia.)
Claro, ¿Cómo competir contra semejantes
grupos que además están protegidos por el
gobierno y que cuentan con todo tipo de privilegios?
Suena difícil ¿Verdad?
En Alemania, en cambio, la apuesta política
fue completamente diferente y se centró en
crear un mercado muy competitivo con muchas
pequeñas y medianas empresas.
Ojo, ¿Hay grandes grupos industriales? Por
supuesto, y es algo bueno, siempre y cuando
no dependan del gobierno ni reciban privilegios
que impidan la competencia.
El resultado es que los grandes grupos japonés
han tenido muchos y la mayoría han desaparecido
o quebrado en algún momento.
Pero aquí no acaba todo….
LA POLÍTICA DEL DESCUENTO
Durante años, los políticos japonés pensaron
que para exportar más devaluar de vez en
cuando la moneda pues… no era algo malo.
Sin embargo, en 1985, empezaron los problemas
de verdad. Atentos.
(Como consecuencia de todas estas guerras
de divisas, Estados Unidos tenía un déficit
exterior bastante grande.
Y como a políticos de entonces en Washington,
como a los de ahora esto, no les hacía ninguna
gracia, forzaron los llamados “Acuerdos
de Plaza”, un acuerdo entre Estados Unidos,
Japón, Alemania, Francia y Reino Unido para
depreciar el dólar con el objetivo de reducir
este déficit comercial.)
Pues bien, cómo os podéis imaginar esto
supuso todo un mazazo para la industria japonesa
que estaba acostumbrada a competir con alguna
que otra ayuda.
Y ¿Qué pensáis que hizo el gobierno?
Pues decirles, tranquilos aquí estoy yo para
salvaros. Así que, dicho y hecho: el Gobierno japonés
hundió los tipos de interés y empezó a impulsar
el crédito como si no hubiese mañana.
¿El resultado? Una enorme espiral de duda,
bancos que repartían dinero a lo loco y una
descomunal burbuja en el mercado inmobiliario
y en los mercados financieros.
Y ¿Qué creéis que pasó? Pues que 1990
todo este castillo de naipes comenzó a venirse abajo...
En Alemania en cambio, también lo hemos visto
aquí en VisualPolitik, el gobierno apostó
por mantener un marco fuerte, lo que por un
lado obligaba a las empresas a competir en
productividad e innovación, pero por otro
les permitía comprar tecnología y maquinas
extranjeras con mejores condiciones.
Pero, amigos, aun existe una tercera diferencia…
determinante. Atentos.
ENCERRADOS EN SÍ MISMOS
Japón es el país más envejecido del mundo.
Algo más del 25% de su población, es decir 1 de cada 4
japoneses tiene más de 65 años; y cada
hora que pasa la población del país desciende
en 50 personas.
(Tal como lo escuchais. De hecho, el propio
gobierno de Japón espera que la población
del país caiga por debajo de los 100 millones
de personas antes del años 2050.
Y claro, más ancianos, menos jóvenes y menos
población pues tiene consecuencias claras:
por un lado más gasto público en pensiones
o sanidad, por otro menos mano de obra.)
Es verdad, muchos otros países desarrollados
también tienen este problema. Pero es que
el caso de Japón es con diferencia el mayor
de todos. Y no lo es por casualidad, para nada.
Por un lado, amigos, las empresas han compensado
todos los problemas que han causado las malas
políticas que hemos visto en este vídeo,
obligando a sus empleados a trabajar muchas
más horas que las se trabajan en el resto
de países desarrollados… lo que deja poco
tiempo libre para pensar en formar una familia.
Por otro lado, lo vimos aquí en VisualPolitik,
mientras que algunos países como, por ejemplo,
Alemania, han favorecido la llegada de muchos
inmigrantes que suelen tener tasas de crecimiento
demográfico más altas, en Japón les han
cerrado las puertas.
De hecho, cuando los organismos internacionales
le dicen a Tokyo que tienen abrir sus fronteras a
la innmigración para enfrentar el problema
del envejecimiento… bueno desde el gobierno
japones han llegado a decir cosas como está.
“El ministro de Finanzas japonés pide a
los ancianos que 'se den prisa en morir”
En fin amigos, estas son fundamentalmente
las causas que han hecho que Japón sea un
país que vive una especie de crisis continua;
y también las causas que han hecho que el
modelo alemán haya claramente sido superior
al modelo japones.
Pero ahora, turno para ti.
¿Crees que Japón logrará superar este periodo
de estancamiento y crisis permanente?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.